Welcome to the Man of Recaps,
this is Loki, season two.
At the end of season one, Loki and Sylvie
met the mysterious man behind the TVA,
“He Who Remains,” we know he's Kang.
Sylvie wanted to free the timeline
from the TVA's rule, so she killed him!
She kick Loki back to the TVA, where his
new best friend Mobius doesn't remember him.
Loki has another problem, whoa!
He's slipping through time.
He’s slipping between the
present TVA and the past TVA,
when He Who Remains had a statue of himself,
before he rebranded as the “Time Keepers.”
In the present TVA, the Sacred
Timeline has been branching,
they've got a multiverse now!
Now that they know the Time Keepers are fake,
They've stopped pruning branches,
gonna let them grow.
Now Loki slips back to the present
and fills them in about He Who Remains.
And gives them the bad news
about these new timelines:
all the Kang variants will have a
Multiversal war that destroys everything.
But first they got to stop Loki's time slipping,
so they go down to maintenance
and meet Ouroboros, O.B. for short.
He doesn't know how to stop time slipping,
but Loki just slipped to the past
and filled him in,
so he had a long time to work on it
and “Oh, I do know how to stop it.”
They go to the core of the TVA,
the Temporal Loom.
Mobius has to venture outside and shoot
an anchor into the timeline.
Then Loki has to prune himself,
but oh he slips away right now,
and is desperately searching
for a prune stick.
And he's surprised to find
Sylvie in an elevator,
then woah! He's pruned from
behind... More on this later.
But anyway it works, and Loki's
back, anchored in the present.
So Loki and Mobius take a pie break
to figure out what to do next.
While their other friends
Hunter B-15 and the tech Casey,
go down to see O.B. and help him out.
But one TVA general goes off
on a mission to hunt down Sylvie,
so Loki and Mobius got to track down
one of her hunters who has now left,
for a life on the timeline
as a 70’s movie star.
They convince him to tell them
Sylvie's location,
she's working at a McDonald's in the 1980s.
So our Loki-variant lovebirds have a chat,
“The TVA needs your help.”
“I don't care, I just want
to live a normal life.”
But right now that rogue general
is trying to prune this timeline,
as well as a bunch of others, so Sylvie
has to help put a stop to that.
Now there's a new problem
with Judge Renslayer,
who's working with Miss Minutes on a
contingency plan from He Who Remains.
They drop a TVA handbook into the window
of this kid from the 1800s.
Loki and Mobius follow her trail, which
leads to the 1893 Chicago World's Fair.
That kid has grown up into Victor Timely,
an eccentric inventor,
who Loki recognizes as a
variant of He Who Remains.
So all our time travelers are fighting to
get him, it turns into a whole thing.
Sylvie wants to kill him so he can't
become another He Who Remains,
but he's like, “Yo, that guy wasn't me.”
And as a variant herself,
Sylvie understands,
so she lets him live and kicks
Renslayer out of there.
Now they need Victor Timely’s
help to save the TVA,
because the Temporal Loom is overloading,
it wasn't designed to
handle multiple timelines.
He's excited to meet the Ouroboros
who wrote the TVA handbook,
but turns out O.B. only wrote it
based on notes from Victor Timely,
Whoa! Time paradox!
So together they invent the science thing
that will let the loom
have multiple timelines.
Meanwhile Renslayer and Miss Minutes
are at the end of time,
where Miss Minutes fills her in on
who she was before the TVA.
She was his top general, who
basically won the Kang War for him.
They were supposed to rule
the Sacred Timeline together,
but he erased her memory
just like everyone else's!
So now she's real mad.
She and Miss Minutes capture Victor Timely,
they're going to lead TVA coup.
Loki’s running to stop them, but first
he runs into his past self.
So oh! He prunes himself!
Classic time paradox.
Now they save Victor Timely,
Sylvie mind controls the movie
star who prunes Renslayer.
But remember when you're pruned
you're just sent to the end of time,
so Renslayer’s still kicking around out there.
But now they've got to rush
to do the science thing
to stop the Temporal Loom from overloading.
Victor Timely goes out there
for his big hero moment,
But oh! It doesn't work,
he's ripped to shreds!
Yeah, they just took too long.
And now the Loom explodes!
And the TVA is destroyed.
But Loki's okay, for some reason
he starts time slipping again.
He slips to a jet ski store...
Yeah, remember Mobius loves jet skis!
His real life was a jet ski salesman.
Loki's like, “Mobius, I need your
help to save the timeline.”
But it's like, “Who's Mobius?
My name's Don.”
Now Loki slips over to O.B.,
who's not a scientist, he's a failed
science fiction writer.
But he does have a degree
in theoretical physics,
so he's able to learn about time travel
from the TVA handbook
that he would eventually write...
Time paradox!
So in a few years of his time
but one minute of Loki's,
O.B. invents a TemPad and
they go back to see Mobius.
It's like, “Dude, I know you
have a life and kids,”
“but you're the only one
who can save the multiverse.”
“And you won't miss anything,
because with time travel,”
“we’ll bring you right back
here when it's all done.”
So Loki recruits all his friends
from their lives on the timeline.
But his last recruit is Sylvie,
who doesn't want to help.
She's like, “The multiverse is
better off without the TVA.”
But turns out, it's not.
Without the Temporal Loom powering
the timelines, they're all fading away.
And so this is it,
it's the end of everything.
Until Loki learns to
control his time slipping!
He travels back to the moment
they're saving the Loom,
like “Yo, we got to go faster this time.”
And so it's time for a classic time loop,
where Loki redoes this over and over again,
but it always fails.
So Loki tries going back
earlier in the day,
to help them invent the
science thing faster.
Finally he realizes it'll just be faster
if they teach him how to build it.
They're like, “Uh, we
don't have time for that.”
But he's like, “Trust me, we do.”
And so, centuries later, we
catch up with master scientist Loki,
who's able to get them
out there real quick.
He guides them through all the problems
that have gone wrong
over thousands of loops.
But this one is it, they actually do it!
The day is saved!
Except it's not, the Loom is still overloading.
They realize because the
timelines are growing infinitely,
no matter how much they
increase the Loom’s capacity,
it will never be enough.
So now Loki has to go back even
further, to the end of season one!
And stop Sylvie from killing
He Who Remains.
He tries to tell her killing him won't work,
it just ends up destroying the universe.
But this past Sylvie doesn't believe him,
she always goes and kills him anyway.
Eventually He Who Remains steps in,
“So Loki, how many loops is this for you?”
Yeah, he's aware of the whole situation.
He explains how the Temporal Loom
overloading is part of its design,
so that even if he dies, it
will lead them right back here.
He's like, “Look, Loki,
you can't save the multiverse.”
“The only options are the TVA
with my Sacred Timeline, or nothing.”
But Loki comes up with one other option,
a drastic one, but the only
way to save his friends.
He walks on out there himself!
Yeah, remember, as an
Asgardian God, he can take it.
He destroys the Loom
before it can overload,
but this still leaves
all the timelines dying.
But they don't need the
energy from the Loom,
Loki can power them
with his own magic!
But it won't last without
him holding them,
Loki has to stay out here.
So he grabs all the timelines and
takes the throne at the end of time.
Which, ironically, was Loki's
original selfish plan,
to take the throne and
rule all of time.
But instead, Loki finds his new
“glorious purpose,”
is not to rule, but to protect.
He uses himself to power the timelines,
allowing a multiverse to flourish!
In fact, this new multiverse
looks like a tree...
Yggdrasil, the World Tree
of Norse mythology.
And so the TVA has rebuilt,
with a rebooted non-evil Miss Minutes.
Their new mission is not
to prune timelines,
but to let them flourish,
and just keep an eye on it.
Specifically they're watching
for any Kang variants,
to nip any multiversal wars in the bud.
Everything seems to be under control,
and so Agent Mobius is ready to retire.
Time to go home to his
sons and his Sea-Doos.
And Sylvie is now finally free
to go live whatever
normal life she wants.
But this happy ending is bittersweet,
because it's all made possible by
Loki, our new God of Time,
sacrificing himself by
sitting here for eternity,
a real lonely existence.
And that's how Loki season two
comes to an end.
If you liked this recap,
hit that Subscribe button
for more of the best
recaps of TV and movies.